mais s'appelle la mecque et tel quel sur
le pied va mais j'ai le nom bout de la
langue
il s'appelle je sais pas il va sortir un
disque bientôt d'ailleurs non alors
deuxième actualité de françoise hardy
donc le livre les rythmes du zodiaque
c'est au cherche midi
alors on va prendre les choses dans
l'ordre parce que c'est vrai que c'est
hélas trop logis des faits cela peut
sembler un peu compliqué alors ça les
voilà ça l'est et donc quand on vous
demande sur quoi est basée l'astrologie
françoise hardy vous dit tout se passe
comme si le système nerveux du
nouveau-né fixer les rythmes de son
environnement solaire au moment précis
de sa naissance et son environnement
salaires c'est le système solaire dans
des salles
les gens sont tellement cons donc c'est
ça quand on me canton quand on arrive
comme ça au jour à ce moment là on sait
comme il comprendre voilà c'est ça c'est
comme cela semble se passer c'est classe
a le mérite d'être clair ils somment
conviction pour lui tenir contraire je
sais pas mal et je me dis quand on est
dans le monde pourquoi on serait pas
soumis aussi à l' influence cela
pourrait il faut attendre de sortir du
vent n'a pas ce qu'on reçoit directement
il ya plus la protection de la maman
filtre alors le problème à le problème
c'est que depuis plusieurs siècles
l'astrologie est pratiqué par des
astrologues qui ne connaissant rien
astronomique qui était sûr qu'on parlera
d'elisabeth tessier et ça arrive et ça
c'est vrai ça j connaissent rien les
mecs au départ en astrologie était
pratiquée par des astronomes et un
certain moment elle a été interdite
du coup elle est tombée dedans
les mains de gens qui se sont contentés
des symboles astrologique sens sans
spécialement on en met sans savoir ce
que ça recoupe est réellement sans
savoir pourquoi on utilisait ses
symboles et il a fallu attendre le 20e
siècle
la milieu du xxème siècle pour que
surgisse comme par miracle
jean-pierre en créant que la 15e ici ce
sont vous vous levez le pied
d'accord ça fait 30 ans que non mais
c'est le seul qui a fait avancer
l'astrologie et depuis depuis plusieurs
siècles
non mais non la seule chose qu'il faut
préciser c'est que l'astrologie informe
sur l'un de nos conditionnements qui est
justement le conditionnement seles c'est
à dire la situation du système solaire
au moment de notre naissance laquelle se
résume à des rythmes et les quel rythme
nous prédispose à avoir certains
réflexes par rapport au monde par par
exemple capricorne dont vous êtes et a
tendance à tendance à avoir un réflexe
de fermeture par rapport au monde alors
que les gémeaux que vous êtes aussi
entendant sens contraire proposer
l'échangé 6,5
comme vous savez et vous on peut voir ça
mais ils sont très complémentaires y en
a qui peut sécuriser l'autre puis
l'autre qui peut mettre en danger l'un
d'eux c'est nécessaire autant à la
caisse une affaire qui peut qui peut
tourner ce dont je me rends compte c'est
qu'à chaque fois toute façon il ya
toujours quelque chose à dire
évidemment on vous dit que le fait
qu'elle soit capricorne et lui gémeaux
je ne sais plus vierge j'aime bien des
maux si ows est contre indiquée dans sa
voix ensemble ça veut tout dire et mais
non mais non mais là on retombe dans les
trucs parce qu'on peut être beaucoup
plus précis que ça vraiment la vierge et
les dents l'autoprotection donc elle à
l'aller pendant parle elle a des
réflexes sécuritaires de de fermeture au
mans le besoin de se protéger par
rapport au monde être le contraire sont
d'emballant soit sans danger mot
catherine barma ma vie vous êtes
beaucoup mieux qu'il avait testée mais
je suis pas sûr parce que avec vous
c'est très difficile serait s'exprimer
pour la première fois je me sens très
solidaire des abbés petit